if comedy is all about timing John
Stewart's arrival as the host of The
Daily Show was the perfect setup it was
1999 Fox News and MSNBC had just joined
CNN's rolling 24-hour coverage of
breaking news that's really just bait
for ratings when Stewart took over for
The Daily Show the Internet as a news
source and a place to sound off wasn't
what it is today
blogs were just beginning and Twitter
was but a twinkle in a young techies eye
Stuart had already been doing his own
brand of political stand-up comedy for
years and had even done the White House
press Correspondents Dinner in 1997 even
though he joked he was President
Clinton's third choice for the gig but
isn't that what the confirmation process
is all about here in Washington weeding
out the truly qualified to get to the
truly available but it was the Daily
Show that made Jon Stewart and vice
versa he often said he would never be
better suited for anything else and to
our generation it wasn't with the
Washington Post reported that mattered
it was what Stewart said the night
before the show was a light of humor and
truth in pretty dark times stolen
elections 9/11 the Iraq war times when
the mainstream media toed the White
House line instead of reporting it and
when the media consensus was
wall-to-wall patriotic fear and dissent
was drowned out The Daily Show was a
comedic outlet for real frustration he
also exposed the illusion of debate that
cable news often hawks it's called
balance basically it works like this you
get too crazy bald people one
representing the right and one
representing the left it makes sense
those are the only two functional and
rational points of view the anchor helps
them come to a golden consensus it's no
wonder that today one out of ten young
people say he's the most trusted person
in media his fake news was more real
than most things on cable the segment's
were thorough and well researched and
his use of jokes and sketches we're
tools journalists didn't have at their
disposal and they allowed him to make
more nuanced points and as a comedian he
have to be accountable to anything
except audience laughter but he gained
enough trust to be able to sometimes put
the comedy on hold and get real like
after the non indictment of the cop who
killed Eric garner
if comedy is tragedy plus time I need
more time but I would really settle for
less tragedy to be honest with you well
Stuart spent a lot of time critiquing
the media he also revolutionized it
without him there would of course not
have been the spin-offs of Colbert
Oliver and Wilmore but they're also
probably wouldn't be a Rachel Maddow
Show The Young Turks or shirtless
Russell Brand waxing political or little
journal comics like me The Daily Show
didn't just teach us that fair and
balanced is a key slogan for a certain
right-wing propaganda channel but that
in news there's always bias and maybe
that bias is okay but only when it's
based in fact not in non-existent WMDs
or a Kenyan birth certificate Stewart
also challenged the news media to be
better to do its job and tell the truth
has it risen to that challenge I think
the jury's still out on that one Jon
Stewart is a legend and he'll be missed
on The Daily Show
no pressure Trevor
okay we're with the man himself John
Stuart to have to carry that in a fanny
pack
she wasn't a fanny pack all right